[Music]
yeah thanks for coming out I want to
talk about this not too long ago I
invited you out to lunch okay I said
Dionne let's get some lunch and I said
you could pick the restaurant
yes and you picked a restaurant that I
had never been to before yeah just
thought we mix it up yeah we brought a a
camera crew and we shot our little lunch
date together
let's take a look I invited my friend
Dion Cole out to lunch
I said Dion you picked the place he said
how about Eminem soul food in Inglewood
I've been here about half an hour
no Dion hi thank you for having us it's
my friend Dion how are you good Miss B
is fine all the time oh no you Miss B I
noticed you have a lot of pictures up of
celebrities I don't see mine
[Music]
no there's a bust-up is smothered
smothered pork chops that's a mother
chicken that's mean I'm great with it
so getting the fried bologna sandwich
and the fried catfish yes we'd like some
fried chicken fried chicken is there a
young as there a hospital nearby yes
where would that be I'm gonna need to
get there quickly when this is done just
so they can crack the chest get out the
heart regarding our day we're fine
hey what about the smothered pork chops
oh yeah we got turkey chop stew pork
sounds worse for me let's get a fork
please
if we're gonna do it let's do it making
sure
tell me get it fried you can't get that
fry can we get it smothered you can't
get that smoke what if we get the mac
and cheese I take some of the gravy yes
[Applause]
so far I think this is going well yeah
you nervous me being here yeah check out
Ike Turner he used to come here my guess
is he liked the battered chicken
straight up oh wow that is sweet it's
fantastic I think if you drink to hear
diabetes how often do you eat
soul food would you say Oh every time I
go Chicago can you bring some back on
the plane with you to say sure does it
travel well so yeah would he put it in
Cool Whip balls and you put it in Cool
Whip books yeah do you carry that honors
I have to go in your luggage
you carry it on so the TSA they're
taking away my shampoo it's that big but
they're letting you on the plane with
seven cool whip balls fill the soul food
if they black there let me
yeah
[Music]
it's not coming quickly miss me I swear
to God other people are getting served
before us I feel almost as a son being
discriminated is that possible had to
put up with this kind of treatment for
the 15 minutes and I will not stand for
it anymore oh boy oh that looks great
oh okay look at that that is the catfish
this is fantastic
plenty more gravy we need a lot of gravy
please please even more gravy you can't
bring too much gravy that's just that
okay four more of those please
ripping capacity but I we have a chance
to more napkins see what's wrong with
these pork chops what's wrong with them
beyond no brave they're not smothered I
love it
that's the best one can you put the
gravy on the catfisher do you think you
don't please pal do you want C without
taste never enough
I've never freestyled in my life you
breathing on your mouth yeah
[Music]
I think we're done I use the urinal
about ten minutes ago
and gravy came out how do you eat this
and then go back to work that's my
question
[Music]
I've noticed you disappear
[Laughter]
that was a good laugh it made me hungry
no you're the best all right I'll see a
while oh you too Matt see you later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you ponder this very night no no no no
that was you know I'm not coming to that
we'll take a break last week